hi everybody um my name is Noah shakman
uh I am a contributing editor at Wired
Magazine uh and I've got the honor of uh
moderating our last uh set of panels um
because maybe after seven hours of
learning about all the different ways
that you can be uh spied on from afar uh
you're not sufficiently uh freaked out
and paranoid um I think our next set of
guests will be able to uh take care of
that for you
um uh we're going to do two panels um
first uh to increase your uh paranoia
and freaked outness is uh about turning
your body parts into tools for tracking
you and then we'll get to everybody's
favorite uh topic uh flying Killer
Robots um first panels on Biometrics um
sort of using your body and sometimes
your behaviors to to spot you um which
may sound uh totally weird and totally
uh you know some artifa something new
from the 21st century uh but in fact
Biometrics are um at least 2400 years
old um back uh in in uh 3rd Century BC
uh uh Chinese used handprints and thumb
prints to um to authenticate contracts
and
documents um in the modern era uh in the
1870s uh an employee of the British East
India Company in Bengal used to use uh
fingerprints to uh track his prisoners
there and then uh 15 years after that
and going Halfway Around the World to in
Buenos areus uh was the first case of
using a fingerprint uh to help crack a
murder case When a Woman by the name of
uh francisa roas accused a man of
killing her two small children um the
man was promptly um picked up by the
authorities uh tortured for a long
period of time and uh he still
maintained his innocence and so they
went back and actually checked the crime
scene again found a bloody pal print and
it wound up being uh Mrs Roos herself
self who uh had the print and was
charged with the murder so that's the
first documented case um since then
Biometrics have been expanded uh in the
last uh recent years uh the US
government has funded Research into
using um Biometrics uh everything from
earlobes to body odor uh as unique
identifiers uh they've learned to pick
up uh biometric indicators from Far Far
Away and and also track you by the data
you upload to the cloud which is itself
a kind of biometric which we'll hear
about in a little
bit uh but the applications remain uh
broadly the same as what they were uh
back in uh ancient China and in Buenos
Aras it's what um historians uh I
believe the term was invented here at
Yale might have been Harvard um call The
Shaggy problem uh it's after the um
famous God awful Jamaican rapper who had
a hit in 2001 it wasn't me um sure that
guy looks like that sure looks like my
signature but no it wasn't me um there
may be some guy using my ID card to get
access to this building but no it wasn't
me and uh there may be a Smoking Gun and
a dead guy in my apartment but uh no it
wasn't me who killed him um all of which
may seem benign if a little creppy
creepy um
but the problems come not when
Biometrics are or not exclusively when
when Biometrics are tools of crime
solving or contract enforcement but as a
method to monitor your activities or as
a way to sell stuff to you and to only
you and so uh here to discuss the Shaggy
problem and all other aspects of
Biometrics got an All-Star panel um
first whoa uh to my far right is uh
Jennifer Lynch who's a staff attorney at
the eff working on government
transparency and privacy uh who do we
have after that Travis hi Travis he's a
PhD candidate in media culture and
Communications at myu studying the
social cultural histories of in
identification practices focusing on
Biometrics Ralph is a postdoctor uh
Ralph gross is a postdoctoral fellow at
Carnegie melon and he's the founding
partner and chief scientist at
disruptive robotics
LLC
um Alvaro bedya is the chief Council to
the Senate Judiciary subcommittee on
privacy technology and the law and to
its chairman Senator Al Franken of
Minnesota and last but not least we have
Laura Donahue who's a professor at Law
at
Georgetown um so with that I've I've
asked uh Jennifer to sort of give an
overview to get us started on on various
types of Biometrics and and some of the
legal issues involved so Jennifer want
take it away hi thanks everybody for
coming and I also wanted to thank Margot
and Heather again for organizing such a
great conference it's really been
wonderful to to hear everybody um talk
about location data this morning and as
a transition to Biometrics we thought
we'd start off sort of like Chris did
this morning although much uh lower
technical level um just to get everybody
on the same page about talking about
what Biometrics are so my talk is going
to be split into two parts the first
part I'll talk a little bit about what
Biometrics are and what some of the
privacy issues are with Biometrics and
then I'm going to um then everybody else
is going to talk and we're going to come
back to me and I'll talk about location
data as Biometrics sort of a more out
their aspect of
Biometrics so um to start us off what's
a biometric well um as Noah said they're
unique markers that identify us or that
verify our identity and they're based on
our unique intrinsic physical and
behavioral Char characteristics and
there's some examples up there the most
common are of course fingerprints um DNA
facial recognition um Iris scans are
being used pretty commonly now and palm
prints and then sort of the more out
there ones are gate um Voice or
keystrokes anything that can create a
distinctive pattern um and uh they're
really becoming a part of our daily
lives you can already use a fingerprint
or your face to unlock your phone um you
can use a fingerprint to get into some
gyms um we're already most of us part of
the largest facial recognition database
in the world and that's Facebook if
you're on Facebook or if your picture
has ever been uploaded to Facebook
you're likely part of their facial
recognition database and also most of us
are probably in one of the many
government biometric databases so for
example at least 31 States now use
facial recognition for their DMVs um if
you live in one of those States your
facial recognition ready photograph is
in that day database uh the FBI has a
database of over a 100 million
fingerprints DHS has a database of about
130 million fingerprints um and the
numbers are just increasing every year
um and so to give you a little bit more
information on sort of the technical
aspects of Biometrics when um somebody
captures your biometric whether it's
your fingerprint or your
photograph um it's not that photograph
or that actual physical fingerprint
that's going going into a database
what's happening is that a computer is
turning that into ones and zeros it's
turning that into electronic data and
that data is going into the database
based on a set of Standards that's
developed by a standard setting
organization that data may or may not be
able to be shared with other databases
Travis is going to talk a lot more about
that
um so Biometrics raises its own privacy
challenges
um sorry I'm just making the fonts
different between my notes so it threw
me off a bit um so Biometrics there are
the three characteristics that make
Biometrics so useful also make them
problematic for privacy that's that
they're immutable you can't easily
change your fingerprint or your iris or
your DNA like you could change a social
security number or a driver's license
number they're read readily accessible
we carry them around with us wherever we
go it's very easy for somebody to say
give us your fingerprint um very easy
for us to leave behind a DNA um sample
wherever we go um and they're also
individuating the whole point of
Biometrics is that they distinguish us
from other
people so some Biometrics like facial
recog recognition and DNA also present
additional challenges for privacy
because they can actually tell you more
about a person than just their identity
this is conversation that David Gray and
I had at lunchtime about whether if you
just have a DNA profile how different is
that from a fingerprint if you just have
the amount of information in um that's
extracted from DNA to just to identify
you but the problem is with a DNA sample
and with a facial recognition photograph
you're not just getting that one piece
of information that identifies you like
a number um you're also getting for
example with DNA uh information on a
person's family relationships maybe on
where their ancestors came from their
propensity for genetically um
transmitted diseases in the future um
with facial recognition you might also
be getting because you're getting a
photograph of a person uh if it's a
crowd photo you could get who that
person is in the photograph with who
they're associating with if the
photograph shows how a person's dressed
you might learn about their religious
beliefs or their political beliefs um so
there's a lot more information that you
can get from those types of DNA I mean
excuse me of um biometric identif firers
the other big change in Biometrics
that's going on today is a move from
immediate biometric identification to
remote biometric identification so
immediate biometric identification is
when you get arrested and you get booked
and a law enforcement officer says give
us your fingerprint give us your DNA
that's used immediately in the case of
fingerprints to to run um a scan to see
if you are the person who you say you
are so that's immediate identification
remote biometric identification has now
become possible with some some of the
more modern surveillance Technologies
where you can capture somebody's um
biometric ID from far away um there are
now um telescopes that can capture an
iris scan from about a th000 meters so
the problem with that is that you don't
know when your biometric is being
collected you have no control over that
you have no knowledge if you're ending
up in a database um and it can also
happen on an ongoing and continuous
manner so it raises a lot of the issues
that we've been talking about with
location data collection but moving into
the biometric
context yeah all right let me pull up
my um my
power
okay uh so this stuff the the stuff that
I'm going to be talking about today is
based off of research that was made
possible through research uh through a
presidio murri Grant and with support
from the national day laborers
organization Network Cardoza uh
immigration law clinic uh justice clinic
and the center for constitutional rights
of course all credit is theirs all
mistakes are mine um and I want to talk
about interoperability between Federal
uh biometric databases and um
immigration reform because I'm going to
be talking specific specifically about
the FBI and Department of Homeland
Security's uh secure communities program
um so uh really quick here we
go um so right now this is so this is
the desired end State uh this is taken
from um the dod the dod's uh Financial
year uh 2011 report um right now uh the
the do uh the dod and the DHS don't
actually talk to each other they talk
through the doj they've become
interoperable but they don't really talk
to each other but what they really want
is they want to have um the biometric
templates which is uh what Jen was
talking about the so not the fingerprint
not the images of the fingerprint
themselves not the images of the
pictures um but the zeros and ones to
all actually match up and so that they
can search each other's databases uh the
us right now has a Federated system we
don't have a single single Biometrics
database um we have multiple um and it
gets really complicated when you get
down onto the lower level uh it's
individual states have their own Aid
have their own fingerprint databases
certain times regions have their own
databases but at the federal level
there's really four main databases with
the Department of State not really being
a part of this with and also National
Intelligence agencies having something
like that um but what they're really
working towards and this is something
that's happened uh primarily post
September 11th with all the mandates
towards information sharing uh is that
um all three of these databases uh talk
to each other and can be searched by one
another um and so one of the main
programs that's come out of this is um
between the Department of Justice and uh
the DHS between the aapis system uh
which is now becoming the uh FBI's Next
Generation uh uh identification database
or ngi uh and ident um and what this
what they've called this program is
secure community so essentially what
happens is when uh somebody's arrested
by a local law enforcement agent uh the
uh fingerprints are taken and then sent
to the depart to the FBI for a
background check um that's all well and
good has been happening for quite some
time uh what happens now is it also gets
pinged over towards to Department of
Homeland Security Department of Homeland
Security checks the D checks the
fingerprint against their database and
if there's a match of somebody who has
overstated their visa uh has um is
somehow in ident uh in a way that is not
um is not is shouldn't shouldn't be
there or conversely if they're on a Visa
that would be invalidated by the by the
person having been arrested um they send
a uh a message down to their local ice
agents uh the ice agents then can send
over a detainer request uh to the uh
local law enforcement agency to say hey
hold on to these people please um so
that uh we can go over and interview
them see if we need to support them Etc
um so in their own words um secure
communities according to the DHS is all
about focusing limited resources uh and
using it to to um Char get rid of people
who are charged with serious criminal
offenses and prior prioritize uh
enforcement actions uh for uh aliens
convicted of serious like serious
criminal defenses so they're saying we
want to go after the worst of the worst
right now we we don't have enough money
to really Deport everybody that's here
uh illegally but we want to just go
after those people who are here who are
also criminals um and at this
point uh the secure communities has been
activated in 90% 7% of the jurisdictions
now there's been a little bit of um of
push back and a little bit of fuzziness
about what the program is um because
initially they went to these
jurisdictions and they said hey we want
you to opt in and please let me know if
I'm I'm going to start going over time
we want you to we want you to opt in
this is going to be a great program it's
going to help everybody out um and you
can opt out at any time and it'll be
great um then once they started getting
going they they said you know what and a
couple of jurisdictions particularly
Illinois and um and Boston said you know
what we actually don't like this anymore
we want to opt out uh they they reversed
their ruling and said you know what you
can't opt out I'm sorry but this is this
is happening go with it um and their
reasoning was was they basically changed
the definition of the program so
initially when the program was being
sold it was being sold as the
interoperability right it was being sold
as secure communities is the sharing of
information between the FBI and the
department of
security and then when they said okay no
you can't opt out what they said was
interoperability is its own thing it's
mandated by Congress once you give
information to the federal government
it's you have no say over what happens
with that information so there're a
memoranda of understanding between the
local jurisdictions and the FBI about
what could be done with the with what
could be done with the data they
basically said those are invalid because
once you give it to the feds we can do
whatever we want with it which means we
can share it with the Department of
Family Security and so secure
communities basically they said what it
is is the me the means by which the
department of formand security lets the
local law enforcement agents know that
they want that they want to do something
um so even though they say right here
that 97% of the jurisdictions are
activated on secure communities with
their new definition only 13 states are
only 13 states are actually set up to
get the emails that say Hey you have
somebody in custody that we want to hold
on
to um right and so here's here some of
the statistics about this um so you have
level one offenders uh which are felons
uh level two uh and level three and then
non-criminal immigration violators and
I'm I'm not going to go too deep into
this I just want to point out that with
with in each of these cases the
non-criminal immigration violators are
almost as almost as many if not more in
each case than uh the level one
offenders and so the level one offenders
are the ones that they keep on talking
about they're the ones that they're
selling the program on but ultimately
the people who are level three offenders
or non-criminal immigration violators
are the ones who are just as much being
caught up in this program so if you get
caught by the if you get arrested uh
you're you and ultimately don't get
convicted you're still being you
information still being sent over to the
Department of land security you're still
being caught up in the immigration
system um and this is even worse with uh
the Advent of mobile Biometrics so with
mobile Biometrics uh increasingly local
local law enforcement agents the dod the
doj have this already uh you they have
mobile scanners that can uh do facial
recognition Iris scanning and
fingerprint recognition and they can do
that in the field so if they do a
traffic stop if they don't if they're
not satisfied with the identification
that's being given or if the
identification is not being given they
can then fingerprint the person on the
spot and uh right now at this point um
the FBI has uh mobile devices that can
search iais and ident and um at this
point local law enforcement agencies
have access to uh to a particular set of
um of fingerprints uh including the
immigration violators file uh which are
300,000 people with actionable records
of convicted criminal aliens who have
been deported for drug trafficking
Firearms serious crimes or foreign born
individuals who have violated some
section of the Ina so basically anyone
who has any kind of record with uh with
the Department of home security of
somehow like tripping up on immigration
law can can be scanned uh and can be
have their fingerprints uh checked
against ident checked against that uh in
the
field um so what's the problem with this
the problem there's a couple of
different issues and I'm not a lawyer so
I I can't really get too much into into
the the the nitty-gritty of what might
be problematic But ultimately you have
you have you have information that's
being given up to a local local agency
and ultimately to a federal Agency for a
specific criminal purpose um that's then
being used for for Civ for civil
enforcement and you also have um at the
same time um you have a people who are
being exposed to the ambiguities of uh
being sucked into the immigration system
uh and when you're under suspicion in
the immigration system it's it's not
good right you statuses I mean this is
something that I learned it's just
simply immigration status is not
something that's set it's something
that's often times fuzzy and especially
if you have a Visa status that's
dependent on on you um not being a
criminal you being arrested then makes
that really really fuzzy right so the ma
the major D danger with this is people
being sucked into this fuzzy situation
um there's there's a case of one guy who
got pulled over because his uh his
boss's truck he was here legally on a
visiting workers pass I got pulled over
because his boss's trucks uh license was
uh uh registration was expired he got he
got pulled in took a it took a month to
process and by the time that month has
had gotten up he was deported because
his Visa had expired um so the so so
there are real real dangers and real
harms with this that are potential and
so I want to talk really really quick
about um
what where this kind of comes from and
where the potential for this is and so I
did this work primarily with a with a
group of immigration rights activists
and they were all you know very much
against secure communities but they're
also very much for the DREAM Act and for
immigration reform uh which is great
right the DREAM Act yay kids you know
should be able to be here if legally if
they're if they're um if they you know
are have done what they should so but
the dream acts there's a couple of
different requirements you have to be in
uh entry to the United States by the uh
before the age of age 16 you must have
been president in the United States for
at least five consecutive years uh you
have to have graduated from high school
or obtained a g GED and you must have
good moral character which means uh you
can't have you can't have violated any
laws you have to give up your Biometrics
you have to go through a background
check you have to become you have to get
registered into the system um similarly
immigration reform uh calls for pro uh
creating a provisional uh legal status
um that means that you submit biometric
data you pass criminal background and
National Security checks and um and it
calls for uh basically and it calls for
the deportation of criminals which means
the secure secure communities
so with these with the institution of
progressive reform what you have is you
have this you have an entrenchment of
these surveillance these surveillance um
tools because you in order to say we
want to keep the good guys we want to
keep the good immigrants you have to be
able to identify who they are and by in
doing so you have to then create the
distinction between the bad immigrants
and uh really quick one of the ways in
which modern identification was started
with anthropometry and things like that
were created out of progressive reforms
in the 1800s so this is like an old old
story where they said we want to stop we
want we want to give we don't don't want
to just punish a crime we don't want to
like cut off people's hands because
they're a Thief what we want to do is we
want to say if you're a first-time
offender we want to let go easy on you
so but you have to identify who the
first-time offenders are and separate
them from the people who are the
recidivists and that's where Modern
that's where Modern fenal identification
started is they started doing that and
then they were like oh my gosh we have
so many recidivists where we've got a
mountain of reist but it's just because
they never counted them before right but
initially the plan was to say we want to
actually go lenient and so with the
DREAM Act with immigration reform um in
order to go lenient on people who are
quote unquote like the good guys you
have to actually have surveillance to
figure out who is who is and who is
not great thanks um if you can pass the
keyboard over to
Laura Mouse there
yeah there we
go
can can you do I can't see sure let me
see if I can do it is it on the desktop
yeah it's on the desktop on the right Y
is it this one yes okay very nice you
are awesome how do you get the full
screen just
hit do next one
over
there you
go all right so what I'd like to uh
address today are three things first I'd
like to mention that we really have had
a technological Leap Forward uh in the
Biometrics realm second I'd like to
point out that there's a statutory Gap
in terms of actually having legislation
address this particular area something
that chief judge kazinski amongst others
has pointed out from the bench as well
uh and third I'd like to note that our
jurist Prudence uh both for the Fourth
Amendment as well as for the Fifth
Amendment uh and First Amendment as well
in fifth and 14th due process really
fail to to contemplate the types of
challenges raised by biometric
identification systems so I'll begin
with the with the first which is the
technological leap uh that we've seen in
this particular
area uh as uh I'm not sure we're going
to discuss today the commercial realm
but I do want to just Begin by noting
that Biometrics is not a problem uh uh
unique to the federal government in
terms of its use for instance right now
craft Foods is rored to be in talks with
Facebook uh so that when you walk into
the grocery store you will pass a kiosk
that will identify who you are go to
your Facebook account and then Mark it
to you advertise uh food that might be
appropriate for instance if you have
children ages 10 and eight uh ways you
could spice up dinner with mac and
cheese tonight kind of a thing um in
bars in Chicago there are actual bars
where they have facial recognition
Technologies where you can see how many
men or women are at the bar and can go
to the bar depending on uh which bar
you'd like to attend in Las Vegas there
is a bulletin board outside one of the
hotels where as you walk past they look
at your age and gender and they Market
to you products that they think would
actually fit and race as well and they
market products to you that they think
would actually fit so there is a bigger
issue out there and I took a look at the
patents for this uh between 1970 and
1995 there were less than fewer than 10
patents issued in this area between 95
and 2000 there were 20 we have seen an
explosion of patents in the realm of
biometric Technologies 633 between 2001
and
2011 now for what I'm particularly
interested in the key sectors that we're
seeing growth in are not just commercial
sectors but particularly law enforcement
and National Security and this is where
we're seeing an unusually high number of
patents being granted uh compared to
what has come previously uh so what does
this mean well there are basically four
trends that are going on right now at a
federal level with regard to use of
Biometrics first is we're seeing a move
to what's called multi multimodal
Biometrics which means we're not just
doing fingerprint Technologies but we're
me we're pairing fingerprint with Iris
scans with DNA for instance with other
biometric data that might be there uh
second is we're seeing the pairing of
biographic information with biometric
information so it's not just your
fingerprint in a database but it's also
your telephone number your social
security number uh your children where
you live where you went to school your
neighbors your social network sites all
this information is being put together
into one place uh the third Trend we're
seeing is interoperable databases and
we've just heard about one of these uh
interoperable initiatives but there are
numerous interoperable initiatives
across government so that everybody from
the First Responders on the ground law
enforcement through the Department of
Defense is now gaining access to similar
databases uh and fourth uh in in light
of this trend we're seeing a c apps
between law enforcement and National
Security and Homeland Security as
rationals for these databases so the
databases are expanding to include all
three elements uh and we're seeing
really a blurring of the lines between
these particular areas which matters
because the Court's jurist Prudence in
many ways is built on maintaining these
distinctions between these areas
themselves so I'd like to just give you
one example for a deep dive and I'm
going to start with the FBI uh this is
actually a slide presentation that was
given uh by the bureau bu available uh
online and as you see when they're
considering this was from 2009 and they
have moved particularly in this
direction multimodal multimodal
Biometrics is one of the key areas that
they see as important for the future uh
in fact this push for multimodal
identification uh is seen as important
for them to be able to carry out their
law enforcement function and this in
turn drives the need for interoperable
databases because you can't come up with
multiple biometric data points unless
you're making use of multiple inputs
into that biometric database
itself in this case uh the FBI is
looking at fusing what is considered
context uh and identity information and
they use as an example two political
rallies uh I'm surprised they're not on
a soap box in a public park knowing
First Amendment jurist Prudence but
there you have it we have two political
rallies and the idea is that you can
identify individuals present at two
different political rallies based on
facial recognition Technologies now the
FBI is looking at building these
biometric uh abilities and making them
interoperable with DHS with DOD and with
other agencies in the federal government
uh they see this as critical to
accomplishing their three missions this
is CRI criminal law to the law
enforcement Mission the domestic uh
domestic preparedness Homeland Security
side of it really and counterterrorism
missions and because the bureau has all
three missions they want one tool that's
going to do all three things for them
well let's take a quick look at what
some these are this is uh just an
example of some of the databases that
have currently been stood up and I'd
like to spend just a moment on what's
called Next Generation identification uh
this program is actually seven different
uh programs within ngi itself the first
one as I've listed up here on the slide
uh is called AIT which is the advanced
fingerprint identification Technology
Program what's interesting about this is
it actually includes not just
fingerprints but automated facial
recognition Tech Technologies it
includes biographic data and other
indicators like telephone numbers email
accounts and so on it also includes a
database called risk or the repository
for individuals of special concern okay
what is risk well according to the FBI
it includes ksts which are known and
suspected terrorists uh as well as quote
other persons of special interest uh
this is not defined anywhere and
attempts to get that information through
Foya have not been successful it also
includes both domestic and foreign data
so in addition to apit the second
program is called rback now this is a
service that the FBI will provide to an
employer where they collect your
biometric identification they give it to
the it's it's given to the FBI and then
if you appear at any civil or criminal
in any civil or criminal context they
will notify your employer that you were
present uh at that activity or that
you've for instance received a ticket or
that you are a suspect in a case and
they explicitly include civil activities
so if you're present at a political
rally for instance it's entirely within
the guidelines of this program uh that
that could be reported back to your
employer uh the third program is called
the disposition reporting improvements
uh then there's a national palm print
that's the fifth there's an enhanced uh
iaus repository uh which allows for
single identity management of biometric
data there's an iris recognition program
that's the sixth and the seventh is
called Interstate photo system which
previously uh you might be able to have
your mug shot for instance in this
database but this has actually been
changed in very important ways uh first
it now allows for bulk transfer of
photographs into this system so you can
load numerous photographs into it at a
time uh second it it draws data from
publicly available sources as well as
privately held sources so it can load um
information from social network sites it
can load information from friends and
colleagues it can uh load information
from your company uh it can load all of
this and it now has video Technologies
attached to it so this means that uh
CCTV footage can be fed into it any
videos found online uh the Technologies
are being built into the system now to
include all this information okay now
why this matters to me is something that
I call uh immediate biometric
identification versus this remote
biometric identification and I'd like to
just highlight five ways that these are
fundamentally different and so far the
courts have really grappled with
immediate biometric identification which
is where you have a case a single
individual is presented generally close
up 0 feet to three feet away or sorry
zero to three inches away that's right
because you have to actually take the
Irish scans although now we can do of
course remote Irish scans uh custodial
you're in custodial detention or you're
actually trying to gain access to a
government facility for instance uh
there's often notice and consent
although not always but often notice and
consent are involved and they tend to be
a onetime or limited occurrence now in
contrast what the technology now allows
us to do with facial recognition and
distance Iris scanning um these other
modalities gate Technologies hormone
sniffing vascular patterns all these
technologies that are being explored
right now in Biometrics is that you can
scan multiple people and you can do it
at a distance at a great distance in
public space without notice and consent
you may be completely unaware that this
is happening and a continuing and
ongoing manner a continuous and ongoing
Manner and I would argue that this is
just fundamentally different than the
way we have conceived a Biometrics
previously and these new technologies
really open Pandora's Box in terms of
privacy concerns First Amendment
concerns and I think there are also some
fifth um Fifth and 14th Amendment due
process issues although I think those
will be eventually resolved uh what is
clear is that at this point on the
statutory side we have yet to Grapple
with those
Technologies specifically on the one
hand we have Broad authority to obtain
personally identifiable information and
I won't go through all of these I've
written a law review article it just
came out in Minnesota law review
actually about a month ago um that goes
into great detail on all of these
statutes uh and and really carefully
goes through to see how they apply or
not to Biometrics but on the one hand we
can collect personally identifiable
information yet the statutes which are
meant to protect privacy for pii have
carve outs for National Security
specific cars carve outs for National
Security so the Privacy Act and the
sorin for instance don't cover broad
video surveillance they do not apply to
State and local government records uh
law enforcement National Security and
classified information is explicitly
Exempted in these in the statutes um it
only applies to US citizens and
companies and the CIA for instance has a
broad exemption applied to all agency
records themselves uh the electronic
Government Act of 2002 and the Privacy
uh the pasas which are expected to be
issued also suspend uh reporting
requirements for law enforcement
purposes and for national security
purposes um if you turn to title three
uh that's specifically in the criminal
law realm that applies to wire and oral
Communications in 1996 we had EA come
along and there it only applies to oral
and not video transfer itself uh this is
specifically where chief judge kazinski
has actually referred in his opinions to
the failure of EA to address this
suggesting that actually this is a
purposeful uh omission and we shouldn't
read EO broadly to apply to Biometrics
or in this case sorry to um audio
transfer of video video recording itself
that we shouldn't read it to apply to
those particular situations uh the
circuits are split by the way on this on
what they should do about it but that's
that I think that is the right opinion
in this particular case
um finally the Constitutional abyss and
I'll end with this uh if we look at our
fourth amendment Doctrine itself uh the
Jones case being the most recent example
which was decided of course on grounds
of trespass as was discussed this
morning uh it doesn't take account of
the types of technologies that we're
discussing with the possible exception
of Iris scans where you could argue that
there's been a penetration of the Body
for the scan of the iris itself for
facial recognition Technologies gate
Technologies hormone sniffing vascular
patterns these other types of Biometrics
uh it doesn't fall within Jones now you
could read Jones with a shadow majority
uh to say that in fact uh when you can
learn that much information in an
ongoing manner about individuals the
court might Court might be ready to move
its understanding of privacy but you
have a good deal of Juris Prudence
cutting against this particularly the
distinction between public space and
private space so Calo the cases where
they're looking from up above the homes
kylo for instance these other cases I it
would be a hard I think it's a hard
argument to make under existing uh
jurist Prudence um there's also this
National Security vers criminal law
distinction in the jurist Prudence where
you have these cases now coming forward
that blur these distinctions and so many
of these tests that have been set up are
not relevant uh to this particular issue
now it is possible that um you could uh
well sorry the fifth am minut sorry I
want to touch very briefly on the Fifth
Amendment uh issue of self-incrimination
that tends to apply to situations where
individuals are prevented from actually
acting or being forced to act in a
certain manner uh and it doesn't fit
with the biometric concept of when you
enter into public space there's a sort
of Citizen beware at this point you are
under surveillance as long as you are in
public space it's not that you are being
forced to take a particular action
itself um the First Amendment questions
of speech and assembly uh if these are
being gathered if this information is
being assumed for national security
purposes uh this fits a fairly rigorous
test that one could adopt under the
First Amendment uh and finally for Fifth
and 14th Amendment due process the more
accurate this technology becomes I think
that your argument in this particular
area Falls uh and so the conclusion uh
that I've reached and I'd actually be
interested to hear what's happening in
Congress is it's actually an issue that
Congress needs to step up to the plate
because this is a new type of Technology
we're no longer dealing with immediate
biometric identification we're dealing
with something called remote biometric
identification where anybody in public
space can be surveyed indefinitely with
that information kept the agencies are
already taking advantage of this they're
making this interoperable and we have
few if any restrictions on the way in
which this information is being stored
kept shared uh and ultimately used
thanks thanks
Laura so um
my main introduction to this actually
before I begin let me just clarify uh I
speaking in a personal capacity um uh
the opinions I'm about to uh give are my
own they're not those of my boss uh or
anyone else in the Senate um I want to
make three points number one that the
future is now for facial recognition uh
number two that this is a big deal and
uh three if I have time that the phone
booth door is very much open with facial
recognition so um the the future is now
you know a lot of people think of facial
recognition as something out of Minority
Report and I think as is clear uh uh
from the presentations today facial
recognition is not something from some
you know weird dystopian distant future
it's it's happening around us right now
you know I'll bet that almost every
single person in this room has a
driver's license a passport and a
Facebook account and if you have those
three things you are definitely part of
one and are probably part of three
different facial recognition databases
and what I'd like to do to give you an
an idea of how pervasive this technology
is is take a deep dive into Facebook so
in late 2010 Facebook rolled out its tag
suggestions program now to the external
Observer all this program did was the
following let's say I took a bunch of
photos of this conference I uploaded
them uh in early 2010 I actually had to
go through all my 20 photos and say
click that's Noah click that's Noah
click that's Noah and Facebook thought
this was really annoying and so what
they did was automate that process and
when tax suggestions is active and it is
right now and everywhere except for
Europe um you upload these photos and it
says hey aren't these guys Noah and then
you say yes or you say no and Noah is
identified very easily in your photos
what's occurring in the back end is that
Facebook has made a face print for you
and it is using every time a close
friend of yours not anyone a close
friend of yours uploads a photo Facebook
scans those photos for your face prints
and then it says hey that's you now um
Facebook didn't just roll out any old
facial recognition database Facebook
actually rolled out what is likely the
largest and most accurate facial
recognition database in private hands
why do I say that at the time of its
rollout Facebook had 800 45 million
members it was rolled out on an opt out
basis and it activated for anyone who
had more than a handful of photos tagged
and the average person actually has 53
photos women have a little more guys
have a little less average is 53 uh now
um assuming a 60% nonparticipation rate
uh uh total number of people who either
don't have enough photos or opted out of
the program assuming a 60% participation
rate Facebook would have a face print
for one out of every 20 people on the
planet assuming a 20% nonparticipation
or opt out rate uh Facebook would have a
face print for one out of every 10
people on the planet um why most
accurate every single time you say no
that's not Noah that's someone else the
algorithm is improved and so in a very
funny sense Facebook has has
crowdsourced the refinement of its
facial recognition database which
happens to be probably the largest in
private hands so you know a lot of
people think okay Facebook has my face
print so what who cares uh um th this is
a big deal why first of all uh
government can get this data and why
would government want this data well
this is not a random sampling of people
the one out of every 10 or one out of
every 20 people in the world who are
part of the state datase happened to be
young happened to be uh uh connected to
the internet happen to have enough money
to have a computer and an internet
connection these are interesting people
and they are people that I would say
either The American or foreign
government would want to know more about
uh uh and I want to cut away to
something wonderful that Laura pointed
out which was that slide from the
FBI okay uh um those political rallies
weren't just any political rallies those
were Obama in Clinton rallies and in a
hearing which we held at the Senate
Judiciary subcommittee on privacy
Senator Franken asked Jerome Pender of
the FBI hey I'm worried uh that there's
going to be a chilling effect on speech
and Mr Pender said well don't worry
because uh you know you can only use
this for a criminal justice purpose the
problem is in all of the states where
the facial recognition pilot has been
rolled out it is technically a crime to
do things like block a sidewalk or crowd
the entrance to a federal building the
kind of thing that occurs naturally in a
peaceful protest um but you don't need
to go all the way to the government to
cause trouble and that cause some kind
of harm here and because there are
definitely scenarios in which there's
misuse by Facebook itself or a person to
another person peer to peer a lot of
people say you know hey who cares
Facebook has my face print you know I
trust Facebook that's not the question
the question is do you trust Facebook 5
10 or 15 years from now because a face
print stays roughly the same between age
20 and age 50 and so during this hearing
Senator Franken actually asked Rob
Sherman manager of priv privacy and
public policy at Facebook Hey can you
promise that you won't sell this data to
third parties and this is verbatim uh uh
not the entirety of of Mr Sherman's
response but this was the initial
response quote it's difficult to know in
the future what Facebook will look like
five or 10 years down the road and so it
is difficult to respond to that
hypothetical
um so uh uh uh finally there are
scenarios in which there are real
personto person harms now a lot of
people might say how you know um what
does that mean this technology is coming
to the street and already has come to
the street in early 2010 uh the Israeli
company face.com rolled out the first
commercial grade high-grade facial
recognition app it was called The Click
app as soon as it was it came out uh an
independent researcher who many of us
know Ashan sutani hacked it and figured
out that you could basically use it to
download the face prints of anyone on
Facebook uh and thus effectively use it
as a universal person identifier on the
street um and mind you this was a
company this wasn't a a back alley
company this is a major company that
took itself very seriously and in fact
prided itself on its privacy protections
uh and it was hacked almost immediately
so um the final thing I want to say is
that the phone booth door is open and
what I mean by that Laura is actually
covered for the most part judge kazinski
wonderfully highlighted that even in
cats it was important that that phone
booth door was closed because even in
cats the court said hey hey hey you have
a privacy in that phone booth but not in
what you knowingly exposed to the public
you can't open the phone booth door yell
out your conversation and say hey that
was a private
conversation every single time you walk
outside you knowingly expose your face
to the public and so constitutionally
this is a great area at at best the
final gloss I will say is is laur's
analysis went through uh step-by-step
the Constitutional Provisions uh uh and
those primarily obviously uh uh uh uh
govern the person government
relationship the Fourth Amendment
relationship commercially there is no
law that expressly regulates this space
so if you think it's bad in Constitution
uh in the Constitutional uh Arena it is
uh uh even more empty and uh uh uh in
the commercial Arena that's
it great thanks
Ralph
oh oh
yeah okay
so I'm going to talk about a series of
experiments that uh we did at carneg
millon uh University a couple of years
ago where we looked at um the converging
of a number of Technology Trends namely
um on one hand the increasing public
self-disclosure of people on online
social networks most notably um the
photos that they upload um continuing
improvements in the face um recognition
face recognizer accuracy which um if you
look at government evaluations of the
technology we've seen that since 1993
the error rates of face recognizers
decreased by a factor of
272 so it's a massive Improvement in in
capability um cloud computing uh
ubiquitous Computing in the form of
smartphones that we all carry around and
uh statistical reidentification
um and we put this all together in in a
number of experiments where we um took
publicly available data from online
social networks um we took off-the-shelf
face recognition um
technology and um we put the two
together um using Amazon Cloud instances
for the purpose of large scale automated
realtime peer-based reidentification
um we did that both using online and
offline data um and we we took a step
further um in order to use it to infer
sensitive personal data um so what we
did in practice was uh download a bunch
of images from a dating website um
download a bunch of images from Facebook
and put those two together using um face
recognizer produced by a company called
pit pad um in order to re-identify
people on the dating website where um
usually you use uh um you're not using
your real name um whereas on Facebook uh
you do use your real name in fact
Facebook really wants you to use your
real name and will punish you if you
don't um and we put the two together um
in order to evaluate if we can um use
face recognition in order to re-identify
people um and in the experiments that we
ran on on a data set that was collected
in the Pittsburgh area we found we were
able to re identify one out of 10
members of the dating website which uh
is a fairly fairly large number um in
the second experiment we um we took that
to the offline world in the sense that
we uh we set up a cheap web camera um on
seu campus and we asked students um to
you know participate in a little study
for a few minutes where we recorded
three images of them um and then we used
the same process uploading it to the
cloud running the face recognizer and
comparing it um against Facebook images
um and in the uh experiment here we were
able to um identify one out of three
subjects um one of the interesting
anecdotes that came about was that one
of the subjects told us beforehand
you're not going to find me because the
main profile image that I have on my
Facebook profile um only shows half of
my face um my the top of my head is
covered by a baseball cap you're not
going to find me well we did find him
because one of his friends uploaded an
image of him in which he was tagged um
which created some surprise on the um
you know subject side um and in the
final so what what I've showed so far is
that we can take um image data um either
from The Real World or from online
sources we use a face recognizer um and
we can link you to a Facebook profile
now in work that we've done in in 2009
um we took information
that um is you know often disclosed on
Facebook profiles which is your date of
birth and your hometown or you know your
likely um you know place of birth um we
combined that with a model of how Social
Security numbers uh used to be uh
assigned um by now in 2011 the Social
Security Administration actually changed
the algorithm and randomized it but um
at the time that our um paper came out
that was still the old algorithm so we
took these two together and we were able
to predict your social security number
based on um date of birth and place of
birth so then the natural question is
well can we combine these two so can I
take um an image of your face can I link
that to a Facebook profile um can I
extract from that Facebook profile um
your date of birth and place of birth if
available or at least extract your real
name and then search other databases for
um for this information in order to
predict your social security number um
and in the experiment that um that we
conducted we were able for 27% of the
subjects that participated we were able
to guess the first five digits of the
social security number um within four
attempts meaning that we got um you know
our algorithm is is probabilistic and it
returns you know likely matches and if
we take the top four of them you know
for 27% of the subjects we were able to
guess that correctly so you know we can
go from a phas and we can end up with uh
a social security number um and this
really highlights a process that um that
has been made possible through the
advance of technology that um you you
could refer to as data acis so you start
up with an anonymous face um you um use
uh a database of face images from
Facebook LinkedIn organizational roster
um and use face recognition in order um
to find the name for that Anonymous
phase and once you have the name you can
query other sources of of information um
and um you infer in the case that we
showed in our experiment um sensitive
information in the form of this s
security number um and you link that
back um to the originally Anonymous
phase um we um we took that even one
step further um in order to show that
you could do that in real time by
building a a smartphone app that
essentially does the same thing which is
um you would hold it up uh to a person's
face um you take an image it's uploaded
to the cloud it runs the face recognizer
finds the Facebook profile and on and on
and on and you know returns uh a a
likely estimate of the social security
number um
so the implications that we we think
this research has is that um you know we
see the beginning of uh face being your
face being a you know conduit between
online and offline data um previously
this is you know a lot more separated
than than it is now um you could see
that as the emergence of we what we call
you know personally predictable
information so you in the case of the
social security number this is clearly a
very sensitive piece of information that
no matter how much effort you put into
trying to protect it you know if I can
predict it from information that's
publicly available there's nothing you
can do yeah I can still predict it um
you know we see that as um you know
potential start of visual facial
searches so if we go back to the um
example that that was brought up before
in like you know taking images of of
crowds um you know if these images are
stored you know um there's no
requirement that I do that time that
search in real time right I can go back
half a year later and run that search or
I can go back a year later and run that
search um and so you know your face is
the key that that potentially holds
together a whole bunch of different
databases um you we've shown that you
know if you give that tools into the
hand of people um you you could do that
kind of like in a peer-to-peer basis you
know running it from from your own
smartphone um and it really raises the
question of you know are your social
networking profiles now becoming your
real ID um that everybody subscribes to
um now let me uh conclude with a few
limitations so um yeah I think we're not
quite there yet where everybody has to
run out and buy their own U you know guy
Fox masks in order to protect themselves
while being on uh on the street so while
you know technology has improved
tremendously you know we're um you can't
do the same experiments or the same
searches that um we've shown on like a
national scale right now um but we think
we're not far from that um so you know
there are still technical limitations um
there's also the question of how do you
get access to these face images um and
you know computational costs while you
know decreasing are still still a factor
um however um you know there's the the
strong suggestion that all of these
limitations are going to disappear
rather quickly um and so you know we
have to really ask ourselves you know
what type of application are we
comfortable with of this technology and
um and all of that data that uh that
enables
it wow it's really interesting uh thanks
Ralph um going to open it up to
questions um but I'll take uh
moderator's uh
prerogative and ask the first one do you
want Oh I was gonna give my talk oh yeah
oh my gosh I'm sorry that's
okay I'll try I got so Fired Up by
Ralph's
talking let me see if I can find it I I
can't actually read it can you see is
there Jennifer Lynch um there are two
one up is that one no no no that's not
it go one up um this is Jen 2013 does it
say part two or part one overview okay
that
one part
two that the
slide
okay okay so this is the second part of
my talk and I'll try and move through it
relatively quickly so that we can get to
questions because I'm all I'm sure
you're all getting a little tired of
sitting in your seats um so I wanted to
talk about this crazy concept of
location data as biometric this came out
of a conversation I had with a guy named
Jeff Jonas some of you may know him he's
a chief scientist at IBM he's one of
those guys who just thinks about crazy
stuff he's also done a lot of work on
facial recognition developing um
Technologies for the gaming industry to
identify card sharks um and so Jeff and
I and Chris calibri from the ACLU gave a
talk about a year ago about database
interoperability and Biometrics and Jeff
said hey how about location data as
biometric and I said well that's kind of
crazy what do you mean and he said well
here's what we have you can't have the
same thing in two places at the same
time and you can't have two different
things in the same place at the same
time and that makes location data into
biometric data because our location our
path way through our life is distinct to
ourselves nobody else travels that path
um and even with the variations in our
path that path is still distinctive you
can cancel out the variations as just
noise um and so I have a few examples of
this um before we get to that um so this
is some of what we've covered this
morning about how much data that we get
from cell phones of course cell phones
are location tracking devices uh just on
their own and then as I I think it was
Ed was talking about this morning all of
the technologies that are on our cell
phones all the different apps that we
use on our cell phones also generate um
their own location data that they're
selling to third parties the data is
being deidentified uh but it's
questionable whether it's actually
possible to De identify location data as
I'll talk about a little bit further um
as we move along and um in your movement
your pathway through your life it
reveals where you spend your time when
you're in in a certain place and who
you're there with um and it reveals
what's typical about your your pathway
through life and it also reveals what's
not typical so maybe you're traveling
the same way you're going to work every
day and you're coming home and then one
day you travel a different path and you
go to someplace different maybe you go
to the lesbian bar as Silo was
mentioning this morning or you go to the
abortion clinic or you go to meet um an
associate who's a known criminal um that
creates uh a difference that um Can
alert people to distinctions in your
path so this is um the cell toar as
we've talked about the accuracy of cell
um Tower data this is all the towers
within Four Mile a Four mile radius of
Yale law school you can see there are 74
of them 529 antennas um there's actually
one application for a new tower here um
so this is this can get pretty granular
in the data um so what can you get from
this data well this is a guy named Malta
Spitz he is a or was a German green
party politician and under German data
protection laws he sued his his uh
telecommunications provider for access
to his cell phone records and when he
finally won well settled his lawsuit
before they deleted all of the data
under German data protection laws he got
access to six months of cell phone
records that was every ping that his
cell phone ever made made every number
that he dialed every text message he
ever sent during that 6-month period it
resulted in 35,000 call data records um
he gave that information to a German
newspaper and that newspaper plotted his
path um throughout those six months and
you can actually go to this website and
you can follow where he goes throughout
his day it's pretty great um and the
other thing that the German newspaper
did was they took all of the publicly
available data about Malta and this
included like his tweets um his speaking
engagements um a lot of information from
Facebook and they combined that all and
so you can see where he was on any given
day and also what happened at that time
um so I think malta's path through life
is probably less distinctive to him than
some of us because he probably does a
lot more traveling as a politician but
here's another guy this is Aaron peki
and he is the CEO of a company called
geol lowy it's a data tracking
application you can download for your
iPhone this guy loves geolocation data
he's tracked himself with his own um
software and he's generated 2.5 million
data points over three and a half years
um and this is what he says about the
data he says this is a data portrait of
my life everywhere I've been in the
places I've been most frequently the map
is colored by year so you can see how my
footprint changes over the years
depending on where I live but if you
look at the map I'm going to try and use
my handy little laser pointer here that
this is a that I got from Moro biometric
company so I thought it was appropriate
um if you look right here and then it's
enlarged over here this is where he
frequents in Portland so you've got
outliers like somewhere sometime over
the time period he went out over here
but the for the most part he is right
here in Portland it doesn't matter that
maybe he moved in this year he's really
just hanging out right here in Portland
so that becomes pretty distinctive
that's cool though so then I went to
myself this is I did what probably no
other privacy Advocates do I downloaded
latitude on my cell phone and started
tracking myself for a month I thought
you know if other people do it I should
see what happens latitude has this kind
of crazy feature it's called location
history if you turn it on you can it
will record everywhere you've been over
a given period of time so I've been
tracking myself for a month um in
preparation for a talk I'm giving it
South by Southwest next week to see what
I could come up with and um Tuesday
February 12th right up there I'll use a
laser pointer again it's a pretty
typical day I started from my house here
I went to work at eff back to my house I
went down uh I dropped my son off at
preschool I went back home and then I
picked him up at preschool and I went
back home and if you look at my Tuesdays
they pretty much all look like that um
there's some variation you can see down
here this is low Salos my girlfriend
lives down here so I'm driving down
there a lot um one day I drove out to
Danville I bought a rug
um but you can see that that was just
one day and most of my path is right
here um and even
though the data is not that accurate you
can see like this long line right here
it's not showing you everywhere I was in
between but it's pretty clear I just
went from San Francisco to Los Altos and
back um and so just basically it really
shows you where I've been so where do we
go with that well like I said at the
beginning we're sharing this data with
third parties our cell phone providers
our location applications are sharing
this data with third parties this is an
example of that this is some research
that UC Berkeley and MIT did on traffic
patterns in the Bay Area how did they do
this research well they got 360,000
um mobile phone billing records from Bay
Area customers over a 3-we period and
they got that data from those those uh
mobile phone users um provider the data
was supposedly uh anonymized
deidentified but you know if you look at
the previous slides I don't know how and
if you listen to what Ralph has been
talking about with um whether it's
possible to to Anon anonymize yourself
uh I don't know that it's possible I
mean the whole point of this research
was to determine traffic patterns in the
Bay Area where are people going what are
the bottlenecks that they're creating
with their traffic um and with that data
you can learn where a person is every
day every part of every day um and
what's the distinctive path that they're
traveling through their life
so I think this is a little scary
because location data uh as a biometric
it combines all the problems that we see
with location data that everybody's been
talking about this morning um with all
the problems of Biometrics so non
trespasser surveillance and Biometrics
sort of merge together and some of those
problems as as all of the speakers this
morning have pointed out it shows you
who you're associated with where you go
what you do what's important to you and
it also identifies you and as Laura
pointed out and as many of the speakers
pointed out this morning it's still not
clear what law would protect this kind
of
data awesome where uh I'd be kind of
embarrassed to see my um location
signature at the moment which would be
like from my bedroom to my living room
back to my bedroom back to my living
room um anyway I'm going to take now I'm
going to take moderator
then ask a quick question then I'm going
to open it up to um to you guys and uh
I'm going to ask that nobody throw
anything at me when I ask this question
but just in the interest of Playing
devil's advocate isn't the idea of your
face becoming the sort of universal
recognizer and a bridge between offline
and online data isn't that so what would
you do awesome they ask you what is the
Pres we already know that passwords are
basically useless now that anybody with
a you know decent top computer a given
enough time can can uh can break a
password of any length or
complexity um so isn't it great that our
face is now going to be used because uh
presumably you can't hack your face in
the same way that you can hack a
password you could actually I me
there face recognizers typically um you
need to include a form of liveliness
test so that I can't just take an image
of you and you know when asked to
identify myself just hold out that image
in front of the camera um and then
pretend to be you which is how Japanese
kids got around the facial recognition
on um cigarette detectors is they just
held up magazine pictures of like actors
and okay so non- terrible face
recognition like still isn't there
something great about that I mean in the
same way that DNA has got has been
enormously uh beneficial in in getting
people off of the death row so I think
that ultimately it boils down to uh kind
of definitions of what you think of as
um as privacy and what you think of as
um as that as what I mean because what's
the harm right what's what what is the
problem and Helen nbam is is a chair of
my dissertation committee and she's I'm
giving her full credit for this is
ultimately you we we live we live one
life right but we have siloed uh aspects
of it right you you what you do with
your doctor is not what you want to have
known at your business what you have
have going on at your business you don't
want to have known at at your doctor um
and uh so the problem with Biometrics is
that it can provide that key that then
breaks down all those barriers right if
your face which is attached to you at
all times right and is um and is for the
most part open at all times can then be
can then be identified in all of these
different locations or in all these
different
contexts that's I think that that's
where the harm the the potential harm
comes right the potential harm comes
with the breaking down of these barriers
the breaking down of
these where your where your identity in
one context is completely is is open and
used in
other yeah I I would just add to that
that I think our traditional concept of
privacy is based on personally
identifiable information is the wrong
way to think about this uh and what
we're looking at is a public or a social
harm that can be caused by these types
of Technologies and the breakdown of how
we have understood traditionally privacy
that is it's based on cause or a
reasonable suspicion you're getting to a
point where this information is kept and
stored and one of the points that you
brought up you know now about the
storage of this information as of March
of 2012 NCTC has issued this is in the
office of the Director of National
Intelligence has issued new guidelines
and instead of for 180 days uh data is
to be kept in mind for five years so for
five years this information of any
database that's acquired by NCTC and
then passed on to other agen
can be kept in mind for years now your
scenario the facial recogn that's part
of that is then associated with data not
just from one point in time from a
suspected crime but from everything you
do for five years surrounding that
particular data point on either side of
it and the problem with that is that
gives you a completely different view of
the individual in society and of society
as a whole and so it seems to me that
what we're coming to is a sort of a
caveat kiwis right citizen beware when
you leave home
you will be recorded and everything you
do everywhere you go will be identified
as associated with you and who you are
in this world and that is a very
different concept of public space than
we have traditionally had like
individual can I make one also
technological distinction um there's a
lot of there's many different kinds of
facial recognition uses so the use where
you're describing where you look at your
phone and it's supposed to recognize you
that's a verification use it's a very
different calculation it's just hey the
phone looks at me and says is this
Alvaro uh uh that
totally different set of PR privacy
considerations much fewer cons concerns
than a scenario where it's a camera
looking at an unknown person trying to
identify that person so the first is a
verification use I think that's awesome
the second is an identification use uh
and that raises a whole slew of other
issues and there's also then that divide
also with facial detection which is what
we what uh Laura was talking about with
the with you know the bar that lets you
know how many guys are are are there um
and
so one of the big distinctions within
like industry is between profiling and
identification and they usually they try
and how they say that they're private
protective is that they say it's doing
one thing or the other it's like well we
we're figuring out whether you're a guy
or not but we don't know your name or
we're trying to figure out your name but
we don't care about anything else about
you um but the thing is is that like uh
with u with uh Ralph's work is that
they're two sides of the same coin and
often times especially with facial
recognition uh one of the hard things
about it is it's camera right I mean
what is the technology we're talking
about here we're not talking about some
weird like the the stingray which is
this kind of this this thing that we're
just now getting you know it's like
highly controlled we're talking about
cameras cameras and algorithms so uh and
the pration of cameras is just you know
there's they're everywhere and that's
that's the technology that we're talking
about in terms of facial
recognition okay we've got the two
microphones here for questions Chris you
want to take the first one yes I have a
question I guess it's either for Ralph
or TR so there are some dating sites
that are used by people who are within
specific protected classes so there are
websites there people for thereit people
who are a particular religion there are
dating websites for people have
particular Kings there are daites for
people have particular protecting
innocent persons do we think think that
in the long term those websites
willable for the
fact go on and M the whole database sign
up
extract the whole database and Link it
people's names and and use it in ways I
mean those
websites because of
the arrested on the BT identification
and was about to
sustainable and the only thing that
saved this yeah it certainly raises
raises a concern about that um so you
know what we showed is that you know
technologically it becomes u a lot
do
that obvious question then is is it
legal for you to do that you know is
there maybe not in the exact scenario
that you described but maybe in others
is there an economic model that would um
you know fuel that that you know would
people then make uh actually make
actually go and implement it um I mean
certainly you know signing up uh to to a
website like you mentioned and then
downloading all the images is you know
most certainly breaking there in terms
of service and then would want to put a
commercial service
on whole my guilty Cent Des that's a
different question you know the what
we've showed is that you know
technologically you get to a point where
you could do it and I think I mean yeah
they're uploading photos I think that
that might have to that that that would
seem the thing that would be difficult
to stop because if you yeah if you can
download the photos then you can you can
run you can run the
I think the real difficulty is coming
from things of data analytics where you
don't know how you're being tracked how
you know where where it's obvious if
you're if you're if you're putting
yourself on a dating website that says
um I'm an atheist and you're putting
your picture up and all of a sudden all
of your Facebook profile you know ads
are like
atheism. right um there's an obvious
link and you're like oh they must have
cookies or they you know there was
something here that like linked me to
that but I think that where the danger
is coming is when there's so many
different pieces of information that
it's impossible to know exactly what
you're doing right where profiling
becomes a type of discrimination where
you have different prices where you have
different ads where you have different
things being shown to you and given to
you and the thing is is that it's in the
it's in the interest of the companies
who run these algorithms and who do this
data mining not to let you know what
it's what how to how to manipulate
because if you manipulate it you can you
can gain the system you can get the
lower price you can always have
advertisements that you know aren't you
know are completely IR revent IR
relevant and you can go to the bathroom
dur right and so it's in their interest
to keep the algorithm black booxed but
if that happens and you can't tell what
you're doing ultimately you can't you
have no influence over your profile and
especially if you're being profiled
wrong and all of a sudden you know I'm
walking down the street and everything
is for Dove soap right it's it pretend
you know there there's it's problematic
that
way I wonder if any of the panelists can
talk a little about the implications
technology on what is a in databas
Facebook that s
wind government's effort to suck up all
the data pass through the uh through the
T lines of the of the internet I think
they're Gathering it up
at
data and apparently they analyzing it
all uh I understand going on Facebook
and checking can they apply this
technology to all that
data
absolutely yeah that that's part of the
point is exactly the question sure can
you repeat the question oh no here we
repeat the question so the question is
so the question is is Facebook is
gathering a lot massive amounts of
information uh a Yoda bite and is
itook oh the government oh yeah NSA yeah
they got in
Utah all of thees and is it possible to
then run run that kind of in technology
against it and yeah I mean the answer is
yes this is what actually wied magazine
had an excellent uh discussion of the
football fields worth of servers right
now that are being run by NSA in order
to process all of this information and
just after 911 the Attorney General
issued guidelines saying all open source
information obtained whether it's
through national security letters
whether it's through voluntarily being
given by telephone companies whatever
the source is that information is to be
kept retained and mined for further
information and if you combine that
right yeah yes oh yes of course right um
and if you combine that then with these
extended uh retention of database
information so uh in order for an entire
database to be transferred to mctc for
instance which is the national
counterterrorism Center at odni it has
to like have terrorism information in it
well it's hard to Envision uh any major
database that doesn't have possibly some
sort of terrorism related information in
it and these databases now are being
kept uh in mind for up to five years so
this is the stated intent of gathering
all of this
information next
question question for Travis Laura and
mainly Al uh privacy so the facial
recognition and historical online track
for
instance can you opt out of your
information being kept or shared right
now it seems like everything is opt in
and if you don't want it then you have
to contact the provider and ask them to
opt you out for sharing your information
or putting on public data website I
would rather that my information is
opted out and if I choose to opt it in
that so that's from a legislative point
Point second back to Travis on the
Privacy issue for instance facial
recognition indeed the Facebook is
amazing however I took Google is
horrible because I got a Sprint phone
and I got the Android was with uh Google
app so anytime I call somebody it
automatically saves those phone numbers
into my Google contacts and I didn't
know they were linked till I looked it
up and it was like that's the people I
called so I called them said yeah you
need to opt out so any Sprint call I
make is saved on my Google profile as
contact so that's one issue that I did
not I took my email Googled it from 1995
came up with my kids pictures from 1995
to my I have no clue where that was
posted or where was it so I had to go
back and change the email and try to
figure out where I've ever posted those
pictures and remove them so if you
Google your phone
then it will link all those datas
together so is there a way to opt out of
the sharing of information rather than
well that's what I'm wondering
automatically opt out rather than
automatically opt in then
have I I I think I follow um but um let
me just say this I mean uh uh our
privacy laws at least purport the ones
we have to be to create optin regimes
where
yes you have to say yes Share my video
data you have to say yes uh cable you
know W wireless carrier providing me
phone service tell someone where I am
and otherwise they can't so to the
extent we do have statutes covering
these commercial areas they do at least
on their faces create opt-in regimes in
practice a lot of folks bury it in terms
of service and you never and and you
click through and suddenly you've opted
into the world uh uh the only other
thing I'll say on this regard is what I
what personal personal opinion speaking
personal capacity what I always see in
my job is people justifying the
involuntary collection of data uh on
totally unrated but distinct voluntary
sharing so you put your photos on
Facebook you opted into Facebook yes I
did uh uh but I didn't opt into uh um
this backend analysis of my data and and
I see that pattern a lot I think Ash
consani calls it inorganic data and I
think there's a lot more inorganic data
than organic data being
collected I just wanted to say yeah one
really quick thing about like the the
pictures of the kids is that um the
Persistence of data is is astounding um
I think one of my favorite my favorite
images of this is that with the UK when
they finally decided to get rid of their
biometric database um they had to
physically destroy everything right
there's a great picture of um of one of
the ministers like putting the the
biometric database into a Giant Shredder
because even though the materi the the
the data is IMM material it it has a
much longer shelf life it it tends to
live on and um now with EUR with Europe
putting in the right to be forgotten um
Facebook and Google are both having to
deal with how do you delete a photo um
it seems like it should be an easy thing
but it's really really not because they
cach it it's every single time it
bounces through a different server they
have to go through and delete every
single instant of that photo and it's
it's not an it's It's seems like it
should be an easy thing but I talked to
some of the engineers it's really really
not and they're just now coming to terms
with how to actually delete a single
photo um off off of their servers do we
have any I just want to add one thing
these are commercial answers to it and
the right to anonymity that we're seeing
now in Europe and the Scarlet Letter
phenomenon you know whether or not you
can recreate yourself I think that's get
very deeply humanistic issues on the
government side the government side of
this question uh you have no right uh to
actually examine any data held on you uh
if there's a national security or law
enforcement purpose behind it so you
have no opportunity to question it look
at it review the records confirm if it's
accurate see how that information was
put into it these are all exceptions
built into the 2002 legislation the 1986
legislation 1978 legislation there are
exceptions for National Security and the
more that this merges with law
enforcement you have fewer and fewer
rights to actually take a look at the
information that's being collected on
you and how it's being
used uh we probably got time for one
more question
thank Jennifer I particularly
appreciated this uh sort of expansion of
the question of what is a biometric and
and thinking about location as being
relevant to that I guess to to build on
the more expansive conception of this I
wonder how um health information might
overlay with this assessment of what
constitutes you know biometric whether
that it's immutable whether it's easily
retrievable obviously with the ADV of
electronic medical records as a sort of
a uh secondary aspect of healthcare
reform and the need to build these huge
and and the existence of databases on
who has diabetes and uh the ability to
do cancer genetics more effectively by
looking at you know histories of
patients um how might that sort of
Legally and and practically um
complicate this assessment of what is or
is not a biometric and um yeah I'm just
sort of curious about the Practical
implications of
that I haven't thought very much about
health records so I should probably
always cut myself off when I say
something like that but um of course I'm
a lawyer so I'll keep talking um I think
that the health record situation raises
a couple different issues one is that
with ealth records there's a really good
reason why we are moving towards ealth
records there's a reason why we're
storing our Health Data electronically
and that is because we can improve our
health care by doing it um if your do if
your data is portable you can take it
from Doctor to doctor to doctor and it's
easier for them to treat you but it also
demonstrates that the risk the risks of
that and that is that once your data is
portable it can move from place to place
to place and it can also be aggregated
with other data um so in terms of Health
Data forming a biometric uh I think that
there are biometrics within that data um
and it just adds to the the picture of
who you are it adds to the ability to
identify you but it raises more distinct
issues about data aggregation and also
about data being collected for one
purpose and used for another purpose
um so really quick just in terms of a
definitional issue Biometrics uh in
terms of how the industry talks about it
is really just about identification of
persistent identity over time um and um
and so it's kind of funny because
there's lots of Biometrics that are
being talked about um like uh EKG and
brain scans and things like that that
just really aren't practical they're
still doing tests on it you know it's
stilling funding for it um but you
really fingerprints Iris scans facial
recognition is kind of still where it's
at because those are just simply it's it
you already have that you don't really
need to do set somebody up with a brain
scan to find out who they are uh over
time um and this is a health records are
actually an instance of Biometrics
actually being like used really well um
because what they do is they use Palm
vein um uh vein recognition where you
you you look at the patterns of the
veins on your hand and it's an
authentication task right it's a
verification task is just simply are you
who you say you are and then this is
being used via for two to um to keep
records uh private um by saying only the
people who have access who should have
access to it can have access to it and
then saying also okay are you the
patient who should be getting this
medicine um and so this is one of those
cases where it's not being used for
identification Palm verification
actually doesn't really work very well
for identification even if you wanted it
to try to use it that way it's so it's
really just for authentication and it
actually is privacy enhancing and um
Heth protect patients so I I would just
add as a two finger on that I'll
authentication is exactly how Biometrics
first entered the law post 911 and it
very quickly morphed into broadscale
identification of remote Biometrics yeah
and but and but then it's it's a
question it's a question of the
technology right um because fingerprints
can be used for broadscale
identification but
not um facial recognition can be used
for identification and verication and
remotely um but Paul B uh for example
you know you can't do it remotely um not
it's not yet and it doesn't really work
very well for ididentification at least
and not again not not quite yet you're
just it's you get too many false
positives okay there's vascular pattern
at a distance okay
okay so I just leave this um we'll wrap
up this half of the panel with um I just
want with one final thought which is you
know right after 911 um facial
recognition in particular was sold as
like a way to catch terrorists in a
crowd right and sort of famously they
put in facial recognition cameras at at
the Super Bowl in Tampa right after 911
but what this panel has made me think is
that actually if you're like a member of
al-Qaeda you might be actually one of
the few people that's not in the facial
recognition database right everybody
else is on fat is on Facebook and
Match.com and whatever and is actively
participating in a in a facial
recognition regime whether they know it
or not it's only if you're really trying
hard to stay out of it or in a place
where those Technologies aren't uh
pervasive uh that you might not be in
that group so in fact the sort of
promise that of catching a terrorist in
the crowd may be the very last thing um
that you can do with facial recognition
I just wanted to Travis and I would
probably say the exact same thing on
this but um despite the slide from uh
the criminal justice Information
Services that that where the FBI is
planning to identify the face in the
crowd as the person moves from one
political rally to the the other the
technology is just not there yet we're
very the computer technology is very
good at identifying a picture of a
person or the the image of a person
who's standing in front of a white wall
looking straight towards the camera uh
and comparing that image with another
person of uh who's standing in front of
a white wall looking straight on at the
camera it's not good at comparing that
person in front of the white wall with a
person uh in a crowd photo it's just not
there yet for a lot of different reasons
that a whole another panel to get into
um um and even helenm bomb has said that
it's it's not for the foreseeable future
that we will be able to do that although
the technology is improving extremely
rapidly okay Laura last comment on this
and then we got to get to the Flying
robots so you're raising the substantive
issue of whether they're actually in the
Facebook uh you know and assuming there
there are other sources you can get
information and photos whether you're a
soldier in Iraq or Iran or wherever you
might be right at the time um but
there's an additional issue which is
pattern not matching so we have seen a
lot of you know query based or subject
based databased data mining but what
we're moving to is pattern-based and
here it's even less less opposite in a
sense because uh while something like
fraud pattern pattern matching and
patternbase matching might work to
identify high frequency events like
fraud that might occur for terrorism
it's almost impossible to come up with
an algorithm for this and so New York
Clearing House you know various uh
agencies have tried to come up with
algorithms and it's even harder with a
massive database to come up with an
algorithm to anticipate who might decide
to engage in in Terrorist activity so
it's actually even less applicable in
some ways in the counterterrorism realm
although we're turning to large
databases as a solution essentially a
silver bullet to try to find those who
are responsible for violence okay I'm
going to cut it off here um thank uh our
panelists
and